[Musica]
stai guardando un video
Ovvio per te dall'altra parte dello
schermo meno ovvio se mi stai guardando
dal vivo non puoi mandare indietro e
soprattutto non puoi mettere la doppia
velocità che L'invenzione migliore degli
ultimi anni mi trovo su un palco
ma anche nella collezione di video sul
sito e sul canale YouTube
un video che per essere realizzato ha
bisogno dei 5 camere 60 volontari luci
un sacco di organizzazione
però ormai in realtà fare video è
diventato semplice Io sono uno youtuber
racconto tutta la mia vita e quello che
faccio con il telefono ogni tanto
lo Poggio qua al lato per registrare
quello che faccio
una volta ero completamente incapace a
fare video e ho le prove esistono sono
live sul mio canale
mi imbrazzano veramente tanto però per
te ho preparato un estratto per farvi
vedere per farti avere un'idea Ciao
ragazzi siamo in 100 Finalmente sono
arrivato a 100 iscritti Magari un giorno
arriverò anche a mille iscritti un
giorno
alcuni direbbero che non sono nulla bla
bla bla bla bla bla però c'è già il
fatto che a guardarmi i video non sono
più mia nonna mi madre mi fratello ha
anche se solo 10 o solo 50 persone le
guardano spontaneamente a me sta bene
dai
buona buonanotte e Questo obiettivo che
mi
intimorisce esatto
questo è esattamente 10 anni fa è stato
il mio punto di partenza e in tutto
questo tempo la mia ossessione è stata
cercare di capire come fare video
migliori di questo
è stato un metodo per tentativi devo
imparare a sbagliando dopo ho imparato
guardandomi indietro e rabbrividendo
guardando la mia vecchia cose Ogni fase
di stallo del successo del mio canale mi
ha insegnato qualcosa di nuovo
tant'è che adesso mi guardo indietro e
penso Cavolo Avrei potuto imparare molte
più in fretta potrei dare un sacco di
consigli al Med passato per imparare più
velocemente Se solo avessi 5 minuti per
passare un po' di tempo col me del
passato Magari gli direi
compra un po' di Bitcoin
Non è vero
gli darai dei consigli pratici
fondamentali per imparare a fare video
anche se non era un talento naturale e
questi stessi consigli sono pareti anche
oggi per te uno trova la tua unicità
non possiamo essere tutti fantastici
meravigliosi viaggiare il mondo
lanciarci da sfogliare altri 40 metri
suonare il piano al contrario bendati
avere una voce fantastica sono cose
meravigliose è molto figo ma c'è spazio
anche per tanto altro e non solamente
video della pressa idraulica o i video
SMR della gente che
ci sono anche persone normali con una
vita normale che si raccontano In
maniera interessante è utile per gli
altri il consiglio numero uno che darà
il me del passato sarebbe quello di
trovare nella mia vita quegli elementi
che mi appassionano che appassionano gli
altri ma di cui ancora non si parla
tanto Un giorno trovarli sarà
impossibile perché ci sarà troppa
competizione Tutti faremo video però
adesso invece e nel futuro prossimo ti
garantisco che c'è spazio per crescere
vuoi sapere se la tua idea è valida
oppure no facile la Cerca su YouTube in
italiano e in inglese e scopre chi l'ha
fatta in quante l'hanno fatta e se
funziona
2 Smettila di vergognarti la cosa numero
uno che mi dicono le persone quando si
tratta di fare video è non posso provare
a fare video senza metterci la faccia
non c'è un altro modo la risposta che
c'è un altro modo solo che se non sei
neanche in grado di metterci la faccia
forse fare video non fa per te Anche
perché per ogni persona che si vergogna
Se non un'altra ugualmente brava che non
si vergogna
io dopo aver premuto orecchie
entravo nel pallone
e invidiavo gli altri youtuber già bravi
già carismatici già famosi e invece io
mi vergognavo anche solo a far vedere i
miei video ai miei genitori Purtroppo in
questo caso non c'è un segreto vero e
proprio da seguire se non accettare il
fatto che ci vergogneremo per forza
Ma questo non si deve fermare
prima iniziamo a vergognarci prima si
renderemo conto di essere diventati
bravi non solo a parlare davanti un
telefono o una fotocamera ma anche a
parlare davanti al nostro capo
il nostro professore oppure sopra un
palco
3 fai video per gli altri e non per te
stesso faccio video per me stesso è una
cosa che io mi dicevo un sacco di volte
in passato ma la verità è che comunicare
implicati l'esistenza di un mittente e
di un destinatario
per cui se noi chiediamo il tempo delle
persone la loro attenzione in cambio
Dobbiamo dargli qualcosa quindi lo
slideshow delle nostre vacanze non serve
a nessuno e anche in realtà il video di
vendita del nostro prodotto sono tutti
contenuti che dicono io io io io io
un contenuto per essere tale deve dare
lo spettatore emozione intrattenimento
informazione
e ispirazione
almeno una di queste cose deve esserci
Quando fate un video dovete pensare a
che serve questa cosa in che modo posso
essere utile agli altri 4 non
complicatevi la vita un video bello per
essere tale non necessita
dell'attrezzatura migliore delle luci
migliori di infiniti piani sequenza di
transizione assurde ma anzi se volete
iniziare a fare video meglio iniziare
col proprio telefono e poi nel caso fare
l'upgrade dell'attrezzatura
questo perché più parti semplice Meno
possibilità hai di sbagliare 5 non
reinventare la ruota esattamente come un
neofita apro un nuovo programma e
utilizza le impostazioni di partenza
anche quando realizzi video devi partire
da formule che già funzionano E questa
cosa io l'ho imparata 10 anni fa perché
è esattamente nel momento in cui io ho
iniziato a copiare il mio canale ha
iniziato a funzionare poi piano piano io
ho trovato il modo di trovare la mia
originalità sono cresciuto è stato
fisiologico
però per crescere ho fatto mille tutte
quelle cose degli altri Creator che mi
piacevano Come impostare un Format che
attrezzatura comprare come strutturare
un video partire da zero non è mai stato
più facile di così sei fatti aiutare
è molto probabile che in realtà hai
qualcosa di molto interessante da dire
ma non è tempo di fare video Anzi sono
proprio le persone che fanno cose
interessanti che non hanno tempo di fare
video perché passano il tempo a fare
cose interessanti in questo caso ci
viene incontro il team c'è una persona
che ci aiuta a scrivere a montare a
girare a pubblicare i nostri video
Perché alcuni in alcuni casi l'unica
soluzione è farsi aiutare
Ed è esattamente quello che faccio io
con Mattia
che da sempre è un mio collaboratore a
fine giornata noi realizziamo i video
scarichiamo il girato prepariamo il
montaggio e più o meno questo impiega
qualche giorno mentre Oggi abbiamo a
disposizione solamente
qualche minuto
sono stato fortunato e in quest'ultimo
decennio di attività perché l'abilità
nel fare video è diventata fondamentale
per tutti una volta hai una tecnica
relegata solamente a piccole Industrie e
appassionati nel corso degli anni è
diventata il modo numero uno per
comunicare più del testo e più delle
immagini Ma questo In realtà noi lo
sappiamo fare video è fondamentale in
tutti gli ambiti
La mia domanda è se già sappiamo che
fare video è importante Come mai così
poche persone sanno fare video bene
L'impressione è che esattamente come il
Mac quindicenne la maggior parte delle
persone non sappiano distinguere la
differenza tra un buon video e un brutto
video specialmente quando lo fanno e
invece saper fare questa differenza è
fondamentale in un sacco di occasioni e
ti faccio qualche esempio proposta di
lavoro e provini quasi tutte necessitano
una videopresentazione Eppure io ti
invito presentazioni ne ho viste tante
brutte in controluce buie con l'eco pene
dei ripensamenti più o meno identiche al
mio video e di ringraziamento recente
scritti però pensate quanto più
penalizzi rispetto agli altri avere un
video così brutto oppure in campo di
investimento pensate a quanti progetti
di crowdfunding Hanno raccolto
investimenti un sacco di soldi solo
grazie al fatto che il video di
presentazione da molto convincente
oppure nella metà della ricerca ci sono
studiosi che si fanno un nome nel loro
campo condividendo sui social adesso i
loro studi
oppure nel campo scolastico non sa cosa
migliore che studiare una lezione noiosa
con un video divertente
con i professori dovrebbero fare i video
per i loro studenti
in realtà un professore di matematica
l'ha fatto si chiama Elia bombardelli è
stato utile non solamente ai suoi
studenti ma tutte quante gli studenti
d'Italia tra cui me il tempo al tempo il
canale si chiamava lestent
che vi possa fare sono infiniti da 10
anni a questa parte io posso dire con
fierezza di essere diventato uno
youtuber a tempo pieno che è un termine
che a molti non piace non piace
utilizzare perché non è il massimo per
quando ci si presenta con i genitori
della propria ragazza
Però io lo utilizzo perché porto alta la
bandiera della mia categoria mi vergogno
molto di più a dire che sono anche un
imprenditore sembra che mi voglio dare
un tono però da due anni a questa parte
ho la mia agenzia con cui aiuto i
Creator a collaborare con le aziende e
aiuto le aziende a diventare più simili
ai Creator questo perché tutto quello
che ho detto a livello personale si
applica con il concetto di Personal
Brand che conosciamo l'importanza di
comunicarsi online di curare la propria
presenza online però sta succedendo che
anche le aziende si stanno trasformando
piano piano
in Creator in piccole agenzie di
comunicazione perché ormai fare
pubblicità per molte aziende non basta
più
la pubblicità non funziona più come una
volta Esiste un concetto che si chiama
banner blinders fa il fatto che le
persone sono immuni alle pubblicità per
cui alcune aziende iniziano a trovare
più vantaggioso fare video non per
vendere ma per aiutare le persone e
creare una community che è quello che vi
ho fatto per 10 anni su YouTube Quindi
io adesso mi ritrovo a dare consigli
alle aziende su come comunicare
e tra l'altro adesso le aziende
tirano fuori candidature di lavoro
proposte di lavoro per persone che
devono andare a fare Creator in azienda
una figura che una volta mitologica
adesso una professione vera e propria
questo perché stanno facendo a gara a
chi per prima si costruisce la propria
community
Questo
era quello che avevo da dire per le
persone brillanti che si vogliono
comunicare online ho conosciuto
imprenditori
artisti filosofi scienziati tutte
persone che trarrebbero beneficio dal
fare video e io sono sicuro che
probabilmente anche tu trarresti lo
stesso beneficio
ti ho promesso
all'inizio
un contenuto in 15 minuti vediamo
cosa abbiamo tirato fuori in cinque
esattamente dieci anni fa è stato il mio
punto di partenza in tutto
questo tempo è minuti per passare un po'
di tempo con me del passato gli darei
dei consigli pratici fondamentali per
imparare a fare video uno trova la tua
unicità vuoi sapere se la tua idea è
valida oppure no Cerca su YouTube in
italiano e in inglese e scopri chi l'ha
fatta in quanti l'hanno fatta e se
funziona due Smettila di vergognarti per
ogni persona e si vergogna se n'è
un'altra ugualmente brava che non si
vergogna 3 fai video per gli altri e non
per te stesso se noi chiediamo il tempo
delle persone la loro attenzione in
cambio Dobbiamo dargli qualcosa 4 non
complicatevi la vita più parti semplice
Meno possibilità hai di sbagliare 5 non
reinventare la ruota e questa cosa io
l'ho imparata 10 anni fa Perché nel
momento in cui io ho iniziato a copiare
il mio canale è iniziato a funzionare
sai Fatti aiutare è molto probabile che
hai qualcosa di molto interessante da
dire ma non è tempo di fare video in
alcuni casi l'unica soluzione è farsi
aiutare
Grazie
[Applauso]